الخساره الكبيره افضل من الافلاس هكذا
يتعامل للمستثمرون بالعملات الرقميه مع
الانهيارات والاضرار التي المت بهذا السوق
اي سرعه التصرف اولا تفاديا لاضرار وخسرات
اكبر في استثماراتهم بحسب صحيفه
ولستريدجولنال فبعد انهيار شركات تداول
العملات الرقميه مثل اف تي اس وهمم سلسله
نتورك يسعى المئات من العملاء لبيع اصولهم
بخصومات كبيره كي لا يضطر الى الانتظار
اشهر او ربما سنوات لمعرفه ما قد يستردونه
منها فاجراءات الافلاس قد لا تضمن لهم
بالضروره نتيجه افضل من عائدات مبيعاتهم
الان كما انها تستغرق وقتا اطول مما يمكن
ان يتحمله عدد من المستثمرين بعضهم يحتاج
الاموال الان عرضت العملات للبيعه عبر
الانترنت من خلال مواقع تديرها شركات
متخصصه بطلبات الافلاس وايضا تمويل
المستحقات من بينها اصول بقيمته
20 مليون دولار تقريبا في اكس سليم منها
اكثر من 91 مليون دولار خاصه بعملاء اف تي
اكس بحسب وول ستريت جولنال كان قطاع
التشفير شهيدا عاما قاسيا واخر الضربات
طلقتها همم كور سينترفك التي اعلنت
افلاسهم
[موسيقى]